before we start i'd like to give a quick
shout out to the sponsors of this video
lord of heroes lord of heroes is an
up-and-coming anime rpg that's
completely free to play
immerse yourself in the world with its
engaging story and spectacular
graphics and effects it's a turn-based
game that could remind you of some other
games while giving you access to almost
50 knights who all come with their own
charms and traits
if you're feeling a bit salty with your
roles i've got some good news for you
add a couple of zeros and turn those one
percent odds into a hundred percent odds
when recruiting characters
because lord of heroes has no character
gacha
why not try that to go for the new
upcoming character sophie in addition to
adding new content
lord of heroes also introduces a brand
new alchemy system for only 2 000
crystals
you get a hero of your choosing and the
best news is that it can be done
three times a month so after watching
this video feel free to click the link
in the description and start playing
lord of heroes
a whole new world of fun awaits
one of the most divisive and
controversial topics in anime history
the overpowered character personally i
like discussing them they're not my
favorite character types
but there's really this unique kind of
enjoyment seeing some characters just
play
one-man armies or blow an opponent out
of the water with insane abilities that
they seemingly keep whipping out of
nowhere whether you love them or hate
them
overpowered characters are here to stay
the year 2020 alone has seen a lot of
them
either on the side of good evil and some
in between
join me as i take a look at some of the
most overpowered characters that made
their presence felt this year
we're not doing a countdown from 1 to 10
this time for the most part because how
can we order these monsters according to
power without causing a whole power
level and who would win debate
so hit that subscribe button and let's
get the ball rolling on this list
the nickname says it all kaido is known
as the strongest creature for good
reason one of the four
emperors this humongous being is one of
the straw hat's toughest adversaries to
date given how long one piece has been
going on
that's really saying something i think
that when it comes to the sheer
intimidation factor few can match up
with
kaido in his overpowering and terrifying
appearance even our heroes are no match
and luffy does go down in one hit and if
that's not enough he also has a devil
fruit that allows him to transform into
a dragon making the monster of an
emperor even more of a threat to all
life in this form his blast breath is
truly one to be afraid of i wonder how
this insane creature
can be overcome once everything's said
and done
time to praise the sun because our next
overpowered character of 2020 is eskimo
from the seven deadly sins
the latest season of seven deadly sins
which aired this year became famous and
trending for a lot of the wrong reasons
a lot of it unfortunately has to do with
how eskenor's fight got handled
however that's got nothing to do with
the state of the character that we're
gonna be focusing on i'm sure that it's
a given now that seven deadly sins
features an interesting take on
shonen where everyone is overpowered
then it makes sense to have someone to
be a special kind of overpowered as we
can see with eskenore
at first glance eskenor doesn't look
like someone so overpowered compared to
his peers but with the help of some
sunlight
the man turns into a beast you just have
to watch or read his fight with meliodas
to see that power in action
the two went blow for blow but when the
smokes cleared it's clear that eskimo
has decisively won the fight
it's not easy to take down meliodus the
leader of the seven deadly sins in
battle but eskenor did it to open up the
year in dominant fashion that makes him
one of the most overpowered characters
in 2020 in my book
[Music]
we resume our list with another freak of
nature in the midst of already powerful
characters eugero hanma
we've seen how anything goes in the
world of baki and like eskenor you have
to be a special kind of overpowered in
order to stand out and make it to this
list luckily for eugero he's the
undisputed strongest character in the
series
no ifs no butts eugero is at the very
top of the barky tear list
and no one even comes close where else
can you see someone who can defeat an
entire army's worth of opponents by
himself
he was just a teenager at that time mind
you and fought his battles with his bare
hands he has an arsenal that consists of
pretty much every martial art known to
man
karate boxing taekwondo you name it if
it's not in his arsenal
he can just learn it and master it
immediately that's just how good he is
the scary part about eugero is that as
insanely powerful as he is physically
he's also quite the cunning fighter
you'd expect to find her that's all
brawn and no brains looking at him but
come on how do you think that brute
strength alone would put him where he is
right now
speaking of taking on armies how about
taking on literal gods
enter the ahmad
to cap off the thrilling ride that is
fate grand order babylonia our heroes
take on literally the biggest enemy that
threatens the continued existence of the
human
race as a whole and they're not just
taking on any god they're taking on
diamond the mother of
all life and that title is not just for
show initially dispatched with one noble
phantasm diamond emerges in her true
form as she begins her march towards
uruk
a march that serves more like a
countdown to destruction as nothing and
i mean nothing
can stop her advancing the good guys
pretty much spend episodes throwing
their best attacks at her to no avail
and even when she plunges down to where
she's at her weakest the hero still had
a lot of trouble in the anime she only
gets defeated with a combination of
trait manipulating powers having her
power source hit talk no jitsu and
gilgamesh's enuma elish on her own weak
spot
what a raid boss it was and the whole
bunch of episodes for the boss fight was
one of the most glorious sequences
in the whole babylonia series
while we're not yet too far from
theamath the mother of all life isn't
the only one who lost just because of an
all your powers combined attack the same
goes for sword art online's final
antagonist in war of underworld
subtilizer
[Music]
our heroes get one case of fake relief
when gabrielle who logged in as dark
lord vector got defeated by none other
than berkeley
getting rid of a god account on the
enemy side is such a big plus but it
seems that the war has been won
well at first at least the bad news for
our protagonist is that gabrielle isn't
truly dead and that he's already
learned the truth of underworld and how
it works when he logs in with his actual
gaming account
subtilizer in a world where willpower
and imagination make everything possible
nothing can compare and stand up to the
deranged machinations inside gabrielle's
mind being able to will and imagine
every attack only adds to his already
insane skills in gaming and real-life
military experience
we already know that kirito is
overpowered but even he needed to get
bailed out multiple times in the
decisive clash
only winning with ally intervention and
the literal powers of every being in
underworld combined in his attack like
theomon it's unlikely that subtilizer
loses clearly in a straight-up fight
against
anyone next member of our overpowered
character cast maintains a sinister
appearance
fresh off a tv series debut we have rai
she's amazing
in the world of webtoons there's a
character synonymous with overpowered
and that's none other than rye of nobles
first off rai is the noblest the most
powerful of the nobles having woken up
years into modern society and not lost a
step kind of like another character that
we'll be featuring further down the line
as a matter of fact i made this joke in
room before
but just look at ry's wiki page and just
look at that list his mere presence is
enough to
scare people and he has the powers to
justify that reaction
even in universe it's agreed upon that
rye is the most powerful character and
the world of nobles has a lot of people
that are no slouches in any definition
of the word then again
with an appearance and a brooding aura
like that are we really surprised
koreans sure love their overpowered
characters i say that because our next
overpowered character is also a korean
creation
so now we move on to jin mori does god
of high school's protagonists live under
the name of the tournament
but say yes
god of high school has had a turbulent
run the most out of the summer 2020
shows i'd say no matter what your
opinion on the adaptation is though
i guess we can agree that for someone
who got an ass kicking as his motivation
to enter the tournament
our protagonist here has flipped the
switch in an astounding manner god of
high school really is an anime that's
all
about fights and it's those fights that
allow the anime team to at least
showcase what jin is capable of he may
not be insane as ry
in terms of power but consider the fact
that jin is just a 17 year old human
right
right i won't be spoiling important plot
points down the line
but without the benefit of hindsight
early gin and his powers are a sight to
behold
if you want to see more of him in action
please read the webtoon for god of high
school
trust me the anime just doesn't show
enough in the adapted episodes
and jin's powers get even crazier the
further you go into the webtoon
[Music]
our runner-up is dengeki bunko's poster
boy for overpowered protagonists
tatsu yashiba
in season one he brought himself back to
life he did the same for his allies he
can decompose all kinds of magic he can
win a shootout against a sniper using
his pistol he can melt a runaway truck
from inside a building the list just
goes on and on and on no wonder he
became a meme character well now that
we've got a second season of irregular
at magic high school airing expect to
see more of the same having read the
light novel i'd say that his feats this
season will be toned down a little bit
but make no mistake
he's still broken the protagonist that
we all laughed at half a decade ago
only a four would underestimate the old
god of high school at least that's what
i would have said had the next character
not existed dansuya would have easily
topped the list but his reign as the
poster boy for overpowered memes gained
a sudden new challenger this 2020.
look for how overpowered he is at least
dansuya still does things within the
bounds of logic in his world
[Music]
and the new poster boy for overpowered
characters in 2020 is
arnos voldegold misfit of demon king
academy really is the one punch man of
power fantasy light novels we make memes
out of tatsuya
but even he had his ever slight moments
where he can't do a no at all not for
annos
in fact a sarcastic person would say
that misfit of demon king academy's
point is all about parodying
the overpowered character archetype and
exaggerating it to hilarious levels i
personally find merit with the character
dynamics and the story in other ways to
defend the show
as not just being such but come on just
look at his feet
he can't even die if he's killed he
kills people without contact only to
revive them
just so he can kill them again he could
transform people at will after beating
them the list just goes on
and on and i don't know if anyone else
would fit the bill of being 2020s mr
overpowered than the demon lord member
of the dengeki bunko trio oh look
we stopped the nine characters do you
have any character in mind to fill out
the list so that we can reach 10 entries
share it with the world in the comments
section below i'd love to see what you
have in mind i mean i also had honorable
mentions in my other way hope you had
fun as we start the race to end 2020.
it's been quite fun despite the year
being a downer overall
and i think that the anime industry had
one great recovery before you leave make
sure to subscribe so that you can be the
first in line for the next vini tube
video
don't forget to check out our sponsors
of this video lord of heroes the link's
in the description
i'll see you next time on vinnie tube
[Music]
you